is for the women the women who live in
the suburbs it's amazing how the women
like me all of a sudden
[Applause]
the president is doing all he can to try
and convince women
specifically suburban white women to
vote for him but he has an uphill climb
a new york times siena college poll
released today shows trump down 23
points to joe biden
among women that's 10 points worse than
he did among women in 2016.
joining me now is gretchen carlson she's
a journalist and activist
and host of the new podcast get the news
gretchen it's so great to see you
um again and to chat with you about all
of these issues
um trump is trying really hard i mean
he's literally begging in some examples
to try to win over suburban white women
suburban white moms um and you know
with covet in the pandemic and so many
families having to make
the decision about how to keep
themselves and their kids safe
um do you think this is this message is
working for him
um and how do you see it um playing
in those communities well first of all
congrats on your show
um and it's great to see you again and
ironically on my on my very first news
podcast today
on quake media i have a segment called
what's keeping me up at night and i
actually talked about this exact topic
about
women who are you know getting the short
end of the stick through this whole
pandemic with regard to child care and
losing their jobs at work and we may
have more women out of work than we've
ever seen before over the last
several decades so this is a huge issue
about trying to
figure out who women are going to vote
for moving forward
after 2020. listen i don't think one
little line of saying hey
suburban women look at me vote for me i
don't think that that's going to
resonate with women
women are a lot smarter than that i
think what people are going to decide on
is the economy i mean that's usually
what it comes down to
and i think that women who voted for
trump before i've said it before and
i'll say it again
they liked his policies and they looked
past
his imperfections with regard to all of
the allegations about assaulting women
um i wrote a new york times op-ed about
this that i don't believe
that it was right to vote policy over
human decency
but that is a personal choice and i
think that that women who are voting for
him
are um simply not looking at his
record with you know how he's allegedly
treated women
do you think though that in in some ways
covet 19 exposes um
what i think is a through line in in
donald trump's presidency
um that a lot of people have brought out
which is the fact that he only cares
about himself i feel like
in a lot of ways that's something that
will anger a lot of women who
you know they're thinking always about
other people they're always thinking
about their families and their children
and trying to keep everyone safe
their parents a lot of us have aging
parents who we're trying to keep safe
through the
pandemic and it feels to me like the
economic message that you
you mentioned it it intersects with
covid do you think the women
of suburbia see that connection
um yes and no i mean i think that we are
in such a state of hyper partisan time
right now
that people hear what they want to hear
and if you
are a woman who's decided that you're
supporting trump probably
not much is going to change your mind on
that um if you're a woman who has
never liked trump and you would never
vote for him for him there's probably
nothing that would get you
to to check the box for him so
i don't think it's a normal election
cycle where you might be able to sway
people
i think that the the independents are
the people that
really both biden and trump should be
going after and are going after
they decide every election and i would
say a close second in this election
are women you showed that poll that he's
down 10
points with women now i don't think just
saying
hey suburban women gets them to suddenly
go oh i think
i'll change my vote
yeah that's a good point four years ago
41
of women uh voted voted for the
president
and and while less women are planning to
vote for him this time around
um it you know to your point there's
still so many of them
and it really does surprise me and i
want to sort of unpack the point you
made
that folks can overlook some of the
misogyny um in order to support maybe
some of the
tax cuts or whatever policies that they
support maybe they are
someone who is opposed to abortion and
so they vote that way
i i still don't understand how they
overlook
all of the other things and do you think
perhaps something like a child
separation policy
factors in differently in their
calculation because it impacts children
not necessarily i mean i i really
believe
that um women who support trump or
support biden have made up
have made up their minds already i mean
i think we're in such hyper partisan
times but you bring up abortion what's
so frustrating for me
as a female journalist and as a female
advocate especially somebody who took on
fox news for
misogyny or alleged misogyny what's so
upsetting to me is that
if we ever ask questions on the debate
stage for women
it's usually only about abortion and i'm
really hoping
that this thursday night at the debate
that we will have other questions that
affect women across this country
we make up half the population and the
last debate there was not one
question about women not one now is that
because there were three
you know white men on the stage i'm not
sure
probably um now we're going to have a
female moderator so will we get
more questions about women that'd be
great but it shouldn't have to be that
way selena
i mean it should be that men ask
questions about women's issues
as well and and i'm really hoping that
they ask questions
that i want them to ask about
non-disclosure agreements and how we
silence women in our society
so but ask any question about a woman's
issue and that'll be a step in the right
direction
i think this is a good point about um
making sure we're asking about women i
mean
we were just a few years ago um we had
to push a movement on twitter to try to
ask women even on red carpets about more
than just what
what they're wearing to try to you know
at least ask
women in hollywood substantive questions
definitely need to ask substantive
questions about the issues that impact
women when it comes to politics that's
just a natural thing
uh last question before uh you have to
go um
disinformation and misinformation is
also a big
factor in this election cycle especially
because of all the conspiracy theories
um and and covet 19 misinformation
that's out there
um i know that you care very much about
facts
do you do you think uh certain media
outlets play into
uh the misinformation and and cause um
you know folks to be misled in the in
the wrong direction when it comes to
what's going on in our country
yeah 100 i mean that's what
really was the genesis of this new news
podcast that i'm doing
monday through friday was i had so many
friends who came to me
and myself with my own personal
frustration where can i go to just get
the facts
it's it's sometimes hard to figure that
out now and so that was the genesis of
creating this
10 to 15 minute podcast every day where
i'm looking at sources from the right
and the left and in the middle
and putting together just the facts of
the top 10 stories of the day
i think that people are clamoring for
that right now
also my last piece of advice cerina is
that you gotta watch something you don't
agree with
every once in a while because we are in
such a state of affairs right now where
people only watch what they want to hear
and that does not bring us together i
don't know about you but i want to see
compromise in this country
i want to go back to where we actually
solved problems
and took on issues and voted things
through on capitol hill
and the only way we can do that is if we
agree to look at another opinion
and respect it and somehow try to come
together
that's my hope with this election in
2020
me too i also want us all to come
together in good faith
good faith debate dialogue over policies
all of that i can get behind gretchen
carlson thank you so much for being here
today
and stay safe